hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the 2019 FIBA World Cup it's
the second game of the blitz section so
Rajab you won the game one of the Blitz
and now if Dean wants to take the
Stormageddon he has to win with the
black pieces which is not an easy task
against someone who who is able to draw
almost any game and that's you know how
our job of goes but yeah what what
opening will Dean choose and how will he
go about it without further ado let's
just check it out and enjoy so a job of
opens with E 4 and 4 when when you need
a win of course
bingos for the sicilian we have c5 sorry
about that
with Knight to f3 buy a job of end d6
and of course B for C captures Knight
captures in the not Knight to f6 with
Knight to c3 in the not Knight to c6
with Bishop to e2 'if I've attacking the
knight and the knight back to b3 Bishop
d7 and Bishop to g5 now so all fairly
standard stuff with castles by abiding
and Bishop captures on f6 now early
giving up the bishop pair but gaining
control of the d5 square with Bishop
captures on f6 and now just getting that
knife to the very nice outpost weave
Bishop to g5 being not allowing Knight
captures on f6 also makes room if
possible to go g6 f5 he would like to
start expanding on on the King side
Bishop to g4 or a job offers a trade of
of more pieces and now Bishop to e6
of course the idea is that if Bishop
captures F captures on e6 gets a
semi-open follow for the rook and f8
also kicks the night away from the d5
square with castles buyer a job of and
now there is one game in the database
for Queen to d7 was played just
preparing to either force the trade on
e6
or for the bishop to move back but here
g6 biding and it is a new move in the
position so as a move 12 we have a
completely new game bunch of characters
on e6 as you don't want to wait for f5
to arrive so Bishop captures on e6 we
have F captors and mountain Knight the
c3 pushing the knight back and Queen to
e7 now developing the Queen can
acting rooks and if if at all possible
you want to get to the rook in the game
and pull the d5 you we have Queen to d3
better job of also connecting rooks and
now rook a to d8 rook rook a to d1 and
now comes a sex taking away the be five
square from from White's pieces also may
be preparing b5 and now a three weave
kink the g7 by dink and Queen to g3 now
just put in putting pressure on that
Bishop there so h5 preparing maybe h4 at
some point and now Knight to e2 by the
job of here being well a job of released
his pressure on the d5 square so a ding
is now able to put d5 and as you all
know when you play the Sicilian and you
can put d5 you you definitely do it
so d5 biding and the now comes Queen to
c3 with a lot of sneaky ideas ok f4 for
for the moment doesn't work because you
can always play d4 and you know get rid
of everything but here basically link is
inviting reserve always inviting
anything to play d4 he wants to get
Quinta c5 in hopefully trade Queens and
get a nice grip on those Queen side
point so ding doesn't want that of
course he has to win this game he plays
rook to f6 with some idea of maybe
creating some nice triple battery along
the F file and now Queen to c5 where a
job offers the Queen trade if not his
plan is to go Queen to b6 get the knight
on to b7 and create some threats here
against the b7 pawn also against the
center Queen to f7 ding of course
declines this and now c3 just keeping an
eye on everything not allowing d4 and
here you have two well for a blitz game
it's impossible but there is one line I
will show it it's it's really hard to
spot it in a blitz game but dink went h4
here but there is Queen to c7 it's just
a just a very tricky move because it
prepares b6 and it's just another
Pleasant square for the White Queen to
be and we're going to
go with the wife Queen there really
aren't all that many squares so let's
say e captures each captors and rook
captures and b5 yes you give back the
pond but now b6 is extremely strong and
after Queen to c4 you can just play
Queen to f7 and it comes with a double
attack on the rook also you're
pressuring DF to pawn so why doesn't
really have the option of bringing the
other rook here but you don't really
have a better move what are you gonna do
I mean you could do it but then just
rook captures on f2 and if rook captures
and e8 you don't really care rook f1
check and after rook captures Bishop to
e3 check if you go back just queen
characters on f1 so rook has the block
but now just Queen captures an f2 King
moves and Queen e1 check forces mate
so Queen to see seven if this was a
classical game completely winning for
for black but of course it's a blitz
game so h4 with h3 better job of and now
rook to d7 of course ding knows that
Queen b6 and night here are coming so
you want to have your defenses ready to
defend the backwards pawn we have it's
not really a backwards pawn it's more of
a weak point it would be a backwards
point if this was like honey this point
was like on a5 but still it's a very
weak point for the moment Queen to b6
better job of in now Rock day
seven-night to c5 is coming so you don't
want to wait with your rook on d7 we
have Knights the c5 and now King to h7
by ding and now before there really
aren't all that many moves now a black
and play and ding is getting very long
time the situation on the clock is one
minute for our job of and 25 seconds for
Dean he pushes d4 and okay her job does
not react with night to d3 putting
pressure on the e5 pawn and rook d7 now
with Queen to c5 and now comes D
captures on c3 we have Queen captures on
c3 and now Bishop back to h6 a for Roger
wants to push b5 we have night the d4
being is now below 10 seconds on the
clock here a knight capture Sundy for e
capture Sun d4 and Queen to c4 still
keeping an option of going b5 we have
Queen to e7 by ding and now Knight to e5
attacking the rook here
look the c7 pushing the Queen back but
now you you're welcome to recapture your
pawn we have Queen captures on d4 and
now Bishop f4 biding but Knight to g4
now with a double attack on the rook
here we have looked back to f7 and now
II five so just the further improving
the position at the f6 square is not
very vulnerable
we've looked Evan ight to cause the rock
in on the seventh rank and now b5 by a
job of a captures B captures a K after
some b5 this everything actually
welcomes this as he gets extra three
seconds on the clock
and now g5 biding we have b6 pushing the
rook away from the seventh rank now he
has to give up the control of the d7
square we have looked the c6 attacking
the pawn and here Queenie for a job of
sets a deadly trap and with very little
time on the clock being just Falls for
it he grabs the pond but even if he
doesn't it's still a much better
position for white so being played rook
captures and b6 but now you are welcome
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning move for a job of in this
position well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on winning
dings Queen and for those of you who
just want to join the show it's this
more than a very nice rook lift rook to
d7 and now next move you're gonna
capture the Queen so Queen captures here
is forced and now Knight to f6 check the
rook on f f5 is pin so ding cannot
recapture we have king to g7 and
mountain Knight captures on d7 so now
the position is of course completely
winning for a job of but being decided
to play a few more moves as you know
it's a few seconds on the clock for each
player anything can happen with Queen to
c4 going after the rook rook the d5 and
now Knight
the c5 preparing to capture on e6 we
have rook captures on e5 and now Knight
captures on e6 way to check which will
completely reduce the material next move
you're gonna capture here if you
captured a knight then you lose the rook
so this is completely winning for a rare
job of and it was in this position uh no
46 that Dingley Rijn resigned the game
and with this our job is the winner of
the 2019
the world cup and he wins a very nice
price of a hundred and ten thousand
dollars whereas Dean gets eighty
thousand dollars it's not all that huge
big difference I mean it is huge but if
you have like if you have a lot of money
it's not but the main point is that both
of them have qualified for the for the
candidates tournament so really just
insane and it's really it's a tough
break for Dean because even in 2017
world cup when he entered the final
seconds Levin ahran ahran
defeated him in the in the final so this
this is the second time being reached
the finals of the Phaedo World Cup and
he is eliminated in the finals so maybe
maybe in maybe into 2021
the one thing again reaches the the
finals maybe he will then be able to win
but obviously he was a more than tired
here everyone was more than tired but it
just seems like our job of is such a
brilliant fighter that it you know
fatigue doesn't get to him that much in
game 1 for example the one we showed in
the rapid section
he was completely lost on a multiple
account but he was just able to
complicate complicate complicate and you
know get on top which usually is not a
problem for ding-ding is just a monster
calculator but here it a job was just
better so yeah you know you win some you
lose some he didn't eliminated Magnus
Carlsen in the sinful Cup in the rapids
in the playoffs but now our job of is
able to take being out before reaching
the Armageddon so very exciting stuff
and the the best thing about this is
that we'll be seeing both our job of
ending in the candidates tournament so
we can expect some really crazy games
there as well
but yeah that's that's it for the
coverage of the feeder World Cup I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you have
enjoyed this game I would like to think
fair diamond I've been in line is Ryan
and Charles trader for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing not the coverage of the
Phaedo World Cup but we will have a poll
about on our next big saga I will of
course check up on your suggestions as I
was really doing all that much of them
during the coverage of the Phaedo World
Cup and we will have the couple Blanca
saga conclusion video which you are
of course eagerly awaiting so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and I will
see you soon have an excellent day